do you regret signing the right to life
bill you know I really don't regret
signing it because uh we we don't need
to be terminating pregnancies on normal
children and I know there's unusual
circumstances uh and I don't regret I
don't regret signing it uh maybe we
should have had more discussion Senator
I've spoken to a woman who nearly bled
to death twice
if the woman had a condition where her
life or health was in Jeopardy she she
should have been able to be treated she
wasn't she wasn't because doctors in
this state were too scared to give her
abortion health care so she nearly blood
staffed twice because of the law that
you co-sponsored well do you apologize
to her that was a bad aspect of the law